is it worth it to rent something instead
of buying it man that's like another
question there's not just say yes or no
answer there is there right and and and
that's a good good a I mean it's good
news right because some so think about
this I own a car you own a car when we
go out on tour we rent cars we rink we
don't go to Lake Isle we're going to
Nashville next month let's buy a car
I'll sell it at the end of tour yeah it
doesn't make sense in fact I do one of
the things I like about about one of the
things I like about ownership is it's
mine and no one else is like messing
with it it's one of the things that
terrified me about renting things at
first but then I think about when I rent
cars they're like pristine when we go to
enterprise I show up and they give us
like a almost a brand-new Toyota Camry
or whatever and it is pristine every
time I get one because they've taken
care of it I mean you're obviously
paying for that as well when you run it
but it makes more sense for us to rent a
vehicle for a couple days than it does
to you know buy a car and we're there
obviously or there sometimes when we go
to a city and it's just like hey let's
just take the uber or lyft option while
we're here yeah and that's essentially
what what you're doing with stuff now is
saying hey the you can own what you want
to own what you truly need but you can
kind of rent the rest yeah and I think
it's also about the cost to you of
owning that thing so in San Francisco if
you in a ladder that's probably taking
up a significant amount of space in your
one-bedroom apartment or your tiny
little deck or whatever and so there's a
classic thousand dollar studio apartment
exactly there's a cost not just the
financial cost of buying it but you have
to also think of the cost to you like
psychologically and with a space in your
home of how much does that's taking up
yeah and so we think about it as you
know it's not just hey this ladder cost
50 bucks so I can rent it for 10 am I
gonna use it more than five times in the
next two years it's about what would
that cost be to me to have that sitting
on my porch for the next two years and
how much would I gain by just being able
to have that show up when I need to but
I also think it is about I mean I'm I'm
always hesitant to like say you know
these sort of global statements about
what you should own or what you
shouldn't because maybe you're super
passionate about home improvement
projects and you have your favorite
ladder that you want every time and you
want to
own that and I think you should be able
to own absolutely but it's you know I
think it's more about having that
evaluation of what are the things that I
need to own and I want to own because of
these religions and reasons versus the
things that I feel like I have to own
because I might need a drill to fix a
thing at some point there's a term you
guys use for this about like the what if
I just in case just in case items yeah
you know how many of those things do
y'all have sitting around the house they
you know what something like Omni or
hopefully many other companies that do
this you could have show up at your door
in two hours when you need to and not
have to own that thing yeah yeah
definitely you know it's funny when I
think about the renting versus owning I
was having a conversation with my
massage therapist with Meryl I hope
she's listening to this shout out but we
were talking about ownership versus
renting when it comes to houses yeah and
we live in LA and if let's say owning
was you know what I wanted to do well a
I'd have to take out a 30-year mortgage
because there's no way I could afford to
pay cash for a home in LA yeah the other
thing too is that I would have to hold
on to that house for like five years
six years to to be able to maybe break
even yet versus renting right versus
renting so right now because you know we
are we're not we're not sold on you know
being here the rest of our lives which
we might be tomorrow we might wake up
and be like yeah we are gonna be here
the rest of our lives right and if
that's the case then I would look at
buying something different but right now
for what we are doing while we're in LA
it's better to rent because again like
buying I would have to hold onto it for
five years and even then like my house I
had a condo in Dayton Ohio and I bought
that in 2009 so it was right after the
crash so I got this really good deal on
this condo had it for six years I lost
twenty thousand I finally was like threw
my hands in the air and I'm like I got
to get rid of this I don't want this
mortgage anymore and I lost twenty
thousand now I had to pay twenty
thousand bucks you know it's fascinating
about that yes no you bought it at the
bottom even though I bought it at the
bottom so a really good deal was losing
twenty thousand dollars not to mention
the you talked about the other calls the
cost of everything you had to deal with
with renting it out to someone when you
move to Montana and fixing things
and just a burden it was the
psychological burden of it sort of
you're weighing on the back of your mind
yeah that's an additional cost that you
can't quantify monetarily I mean I guess
you can everyone could say well yes you
can pay me $200 a month for the
psychological burden but why well I have
to deal with that yeah I mean the reason
why I'm sharing this too is like anyone
out there who is you know having this
question should I rent should I buy a
lot of like for me I bought because of
that blanket statement it's dumb to rent
it's better to own yeah and I never
really looked past that it was just well
this is what society says so I'm gonna
go ahead and I am gonna buy a house
because I've been running for the last
four years and I might as well buy
because this is a better deal and I
don't think we we often think about why
society says that with respect to owning
a home
we the thirty year mortgage is such a
strange thing I would personally never
take out a thirty-year mortgage to to
own a house I can see a case I still
think there's no such thing as a good
debt you know and we'll we'll talk about
that next month we're out on the money
tour that we're on but I can see there's
some debt that is less bad than other
debt and having a you know a 7 or 15
year mortgage you're trying to pay off
really quickly to build up that that
house although I don't I don't tend to
think of owning your own house as an
investment I think sometimes we we
mistake the the ownership of the home
that we're in is like some sort of grand
investment but as you prove to yourself
even after buying this investment
sometimes we we lose money on it and so
I think we've to be really careful about
ownership with respect to well I should
own this because everyone else says I
should own it whether that's a ladder or
a drone or a Chewbacca costume or a howl
bucket yeah you don't want to hear your
Chewbacca impersonations judge
you